100 years ago Fire Lord Sozen used that
come in to begin
bending army harnessed it's incredible
power and dealt a deadly first strike
finally
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix video a lot of you
been asking for updates on the series
what are they going to start casting it
when are we going to get episodes they've
been a lot of different reports about
when the series is actually going to
premiere so we'll break it all down if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the avatar last
airbender videos I will be doing videos
for the series and bonus videos before
it premieres because it will be a little
while before we actually see episodes
there were a lot of people earlier when
I announced that I was doing a new video
that were confused so if you don't know
what's going on Netflix is doing a new
Avatar The Last Airbender series it's
going to be a retelling of the original
animated series on Nickelodeon the
original creators are the ones that are
behind it Bryan Konietzko and Michael
Dante DiMartino they're working with
Nickelodeon and in partnership with
Netflix so it's not like Netflix bought
all of Avatar The Last Airbender they
haven't made the original series
available on Netflix yet but I believe
that they'll do that before they
premiere the live-action series just to
get people ready in case they haven't
watched it in a while although if you do
live outside the United States I believe
there are some countries where the
animated series is available on Netflix
right now the original series was
half-hour animation the new series is
going to be live-action hour-long drama
so obviously the story's going to change a
little bit but they did say they would
be expanding on the story of the
original series so the idea is that
Netflix typically does 8 to 13 episodes
like The Witcher Netflix series is only
going to be 8 episodes because they're
spending more money per episode stranger
things especially with the younger cast
like we're going to have a younger cast
with the live-action Avatar The Last
Airbender typically eight episodes so
don't be surprised that they only do
eight to ten episodes for the first
season of Avatar The Last Airbender on
Netflix when they say they're going
deeper on the characters they just mean
spending more time more scenes more
dialogue with each of the separate team
avatar characters more character
development not them burning through the
story faster and faster because the
original was only three books long 61
episodes if they just did hour-long
episodes and did the exact same story as
the animated series they would be done
with it in three seasons I know
everybody's kind of worried about the
Netflix curse the supposed idea that
Netflix will cancel a series after two
or three seasons no matter how good it
is but the good thing in all this is
that because Disney
is now setting up Disney Plus and
pulling all of its content from Netflix
Netflix needs its Disney
programming in Avatar The Last Airbender
is just one of those type of programs
they can turn it into their own Game of
Thrones if they want to spend enough
money on it which it sounds like they do
that's why it's been more than a year
since they officially announced the
project with this first teaser image of
APPA in the synopsis of the series in
haven't given you any really meaningful
huge updates other than to say that
casting will be open pretty soon a lot
of that early development time has been
figuring out how they're going to get the
bending right because it's going to have to be very special effects heavy and nobody
involved with the project and none of
the fans wanted to look anything like
the live-action avatar the last
airbender movie so just because they've
been really quiet about it recently
doesn't mean anything bad it just means
they've been trying to nail the story
they've been in the writers room for a
while now brining the scripts the
actress that played Toph in the original
series gave a great interview recently
after she met with them talking about
what they were saying about the new
series when casting would happen what
their plans were shooting it were where
that would all happen this comes from
the beyond bending podcast so here's
that clip people had you know started
sending me articles being like hey are
you going to be part of it so I was like
okay so this is the thing that's
happening so I reached out to Mike and
Bryan I came to Los Angeles in May just
for a little bit a couple days and then
I was like hey can I get lunch with you
guys it's been a while huh and just like
want to pick your brain so they're much
more involved with the live-action this
this live-action uh-huh and I just
wanted to hear you know what their
thoughts were and they were on the fence
Nickelodeon was on the fence about
partnering Netflix a lot of things kind
of had to be arranged and it was a bit
crazy apparently but finally got settled
they are scouting places you know up in
Canada for shooting and I asked like are
you fasting soon and were you casting
what's happening and they
trying to keep it as true to kind of
location in the animated series for
real-life so they're focusing on
different sectors of you know northern
Asia and then like Southeast Asia for
like the Earth's tribe in the Fire
Nation they're trying to like
appropriately space it's cool and I was
like you know are you going to happen in
Los Angeles they're like we're trying to
do like a nation flash worldwide search
and try to make it as available as
possible to anybody in anybody that
wants to send in a video and audition
whatever and because we want to find the
right people we don't just want to find
somebody's cousin who happens to know
the producer or whatever right they they
want to find people who are really
represent these characters which i
thought was cool
and a lot of people have been messaging
me being like how do I send in something
like they're far from that point they'll
probably cast like maybe mid-fall
earliest and then start filming like
next spring so there's a long timeline
for things but point is is they're going
to make it accessible to anyone that
will be very public about it whenever
they do start so yeah it's just it's
cool they're going to be very open about it
I think in like a lot more public
because they know that the movie was so
like an that they want people to be on
board for this yeah so it was cool and
they're both doing well and they're
excited it's like be back and like
working on the projects in and with all
like the CGI technology just in the last
10 years it's gotten so so much better I
mean they're doing all sorts of stuff
with various green screens and they're
creating models and doing I mean it's
because you know this world is so
involved and kind of magical you know
for flippered penguins and flying things
you know just like a lot of lot of
detail so that's why it's going to take a
second to get started understandably but
yeah I'm excited for it just after
talking to them because I think they
wanted to be as good as as we do so
basically what she's saying is is that
they're going to start casting really soon
either at the end of this year early
next year and they will start actually
shooting the series till next spring
meaning that if everything goes well
they probably won't premiere till at
least early 2021 there were people
around the world that saw Netflix pages
that they had erected for the new series
that listed 2020 is the release date and
I think that that was something that
they put there
a couple of years ago without really
knowing exactly how things would go down
if you do want a chance to be cast in
the new avatar series though they did
say that they would be going
international with their casting process
and they would let people submit tapes
but Bryan Konietzko specifically said
they would announce when that was going
to start because typically they don't
start casting characters till right
before they need them and they won't
start shooting till the spring so it's
still going to be a while before you can
actually have a chance to send your tape
in if you really want a chance to star
in the new series she said they're
mostly scouting locations to shoot the
series in Canada Vancouver and Toronto
are the two major filming hubs for the
industry with a lot of support because a
lot of their scenes will have to be shot
inside a studio against green screen for
all the special effects or for the
interiors of big buildings when she
talks about all the special effects and
green-screen
testing that they're doing funny
coincidence I did a video about some
test footage that leaked a little while
ago there was a special effects house
that was competing for a bid with
Netflix to work on the new avatar series
some of their test footage leaked out I
did a video about it it's still on my
channel but the producers of that
project contacted me and made me change
some of the video to remove some of
their content they were really pissed
off about it Jeremy Zuckerman already
confirmed that he's coming back to do
music for the new series I think it'll
be a version of the music from the
original series just expanded because
you're going from half-hour animation to
hour-long drama I've already done a
video about how they're trying to bring
back Dante Basco and find a role for him
in the new live-action series obviously
he's not going to be Zuko he's way too old
for that now but he's not quite old
enough for uncle Iroh maybe he'll wind
up being cabbage man maybe he'll wind up
being a random person from the Fire
Nation they also just scored another big
producer reportedly Dan Lin who's this
big super producer Warner Brothers right
now did the lego movie the Sherlock
Holmes movies with Robert Downey jr. I
know a lot of you were disappointed that
people like Giancarlo Volpe and Aaron
AHA's aren't going to be involved with
the new series but both of them have
talked about what Bryan and Mike have
shown them from the pre-production and
all the development stuff they were
really happy with everything that they
saw so pretty much everybody that has
got an early behind-the-scenes look at
this new series has been really hyped up
about it
speaking of Aaron AHA's I actually just
did a video recently about the planned
Avatar The Last Airbender Season 4 story
that he said he had for Azula he
detailed this big breakdown of what he
was going to do with her character so I'll
link that video at the end of this I
know you still have a thousand questions
about what's going on with the new
avatar series if there's any big bonus
videos that you guys want me to do I'll
continue to do avatar bonus videos as we
get more details about the new series
everyone click here for that new avatar
the last airbender season 4 video and
click here for my brand new
Rick and Morty Morty season 4 trailer video. thank you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!